unaussprechlich peinlich ist der
Untertitel des neuen Hörbuchs von melja
bös böse Tagebücher im Mittelpunkt ihre
ersten diebschaften da wollen die
Beteiligten Jungs lieber anonym bleiben
es gibt aber auch Exfreunde von mir die
sich gemeldet haben die sagten mich
kannst alles ruhig erzählen ich fin das
super okay und mein aller allererster
Freund hat sich auch gemeldet per Mail
und wir sind auch schon mal für
provisorisch verabredet wenn ich mal in
Berlin bin Vorlage für das Buch sind
ihre eigenen Tagebücher es gibt also
eine Menge in zu erfahren und jetzt
kommt schon der Knackpunkt das ist gar
nicht so intim weil ich bei der bei der
Bearbeitung meiner Tagebücher
festgestellt habe im Gesprächen auch und
auch eben dadurch dass auf der Bühne
aufführe dass ja alle Mädchen selber
erlebt haben nur die jungen hießen halt
anders weils andere Jungen waren und
deswegen ist es ja im Prinzip gar nicht
intim weil jeder hat ja irgendwann das
erste Mal geküsst in der Online Talkshow
klicksum.de kommt es aber dann doch zu
Intimitäten ihr aktuelles Klopapier eins
mit blauen Blümchen drauf ist sehr
hässlichier wo gibt's das und was kostet
das das gab's bei bei ihr Platz ich weiß
aber nicht wie teuer es war es ist
vierlagig und ist das schön weich
ja super also ich bin ich benutze sehr
viel Klopapier warum sagt mein Freund
weiß ich nicht das ist auch eine total
schwachsinnige Geschichte die keinen
Menschen interessiert aber ich benut
eine ich bin eine
klopapierverschwenderin nein ich benutze
unglaublich viel Klopapier ich weiß
nicht warum wofür alles ja nur dafür ich
ma Roll immer die halbe Rolle ab das ist
sch auch bei Pipi nein jetzt wird echt
in Team aber es ist lustig ich will
brauch mal ich möchte viel Papier
benutzen jetzt ist es raus ansonsten
kennt sich mir ja bös gut mit
Sachbeschädigungen
aus ich habe früher meiner
studentzeit darf man erzählen aber habe
ich mit meinem Bruder mal so in so
studentenkampus Laternen ausgetreten
würde ich jetzt vielleicht heute auch
nicht mehr oder auch nicht nüchtern AMAG
um 3R ist auch doof das war auch
eigentlich glaube ich nur es fing viel
schlimmer an ein Freund meines Bruders
musste pinkeln und ist das waren so
kleine Laternen und hat wollte hinter
eine laterern und hat aber das
Gleichgewicht verloren und dann ist die
ausgegangen das fanden wir extrem lustig
haben gesagt mal gucken wenn man die
anderen Laternen anstupst wir haben sie
auch eigentlich nur angestupst ob auch
und wir haben früher ich komme vom Land
wir haben ja auch wenn wir von Partys
kamen kaukipping gemacht kennt ihr
kaukipping Kühe schlafen im Stehen der
mein der Kamera kennt und wenn man dann
von der Party kommt angeheitert und auf
die Wiese rennt und die Kühe anstößt
fallen die um es passiert den nichts
sind alle wieder aufgestanden man muss
danach nur sehr schnell laufen weil die
erschrecken sich ja laufen dann auch los
wir haben es kaukipping genannt fassen
wir also zusammen und dann hätten man
ich benutze viel Klopapier und habe Kühe
umgeworfen so heißt mein nächstes Buch
noch mehr Geheimnisse in böse Tagebücher
von Mirja
bös